We have an inalienable right to defend ourselves.
A gun is just the tool to make the job easier.
It's nothing for a white guy to walk up and
down the street with his rifle on his back.
And everything's just fine.
When a black person does it, we're a thug, we're an animal, we're about to go stick up a store or something.
Locked and loaded.
Dead center.
I shoot my guns every day.
I train in hand to hand combat every day,
even by myself when no one's around, I train.
Because it may save my life.
But more importantly, it may save the lives
of whoever's with me.
We are marching and organizing to build black
power in this city.
To build black power in this city.
When I talk to people in the African-American
community, I hear they want protection.
There were some guys that came around and
they were shooting protesters, and the protestors
were saying that they were yelling some racial slurs.
And that was when I decided to go back out
there.
You have this history, well before the civil
war of organized black self-defense in
Northern communities where black people were free.
In the post civil war period, the late 19th
and early 20th century you have state officials
who basically are in league with groups like
the Ku Klux Klan.
I think that situation is mitigated to some
extent by the fact that black people
in the South, in fact, are armed and are able to defend
themselves.
So there's a tremendous push in the 1950s
and 1960s for black voter registration.
We've got to make sure that they are reached
and get into the city to do the voting.
The Ku Klux Klan basically decides that they're
going to go after the people who are registering
black voters, intimidate them and kill them.
So you have groups are beginning to be formed,
designed to protect the black community and
protect civil rights workers who are registering
black voters.
The most effective of these, I would argue
was a group called the Deacons for Defense and Justice.
The Deacons for Defense and Justice were basically
black men who had been veterans of the second
world war or the Korean war.
The Panthers were very good at publicity and
not particularly good at protecting black communities.
The Deacons, on the other hand, just very silently let it be known, if you try to harm people in our community,
or the people working with us, it's not going to go very well for you.
Defund the police.
We have an inalienable right to defend ourselves.
A gun is just something that I grab every
day and bring with me hoping that nothing would happen.
But if it ever had to come to that situation,
then at least the option is open.
Our streets.
I get the strangest looks when I walk around
looking like this.
I get the strangest looks more from black
people than white people,
but then black people all of a sudden, you see pride just swell
up in their chest.
When they see me walk around, like this. Like yes, yes he gets it. He knows that he has those rights too.
You're at a protest that is talking about
the inequalities in a justice system and police brutality.
And then you mentally have wired yourself to believe that only the cops should have the gun to protect you and other people.
And I just thought that that was really ironic.
Middle finger to the law.
But yet it's nothing for a white guy to walk
up and down the street with his rifle on his back.
And everything's just fine. NRA, second amendment, it's like nothing.
But when a black person does it, we're a thug, we're an animal. We're about to go stick up a store or something.
But when you see these animals and thugs as
they like to call us, well armed, well-organized,
yeah it makes you stop and think, yeah these
guns aren't just for the racist, the KKK,
the Nazis or than anything else.
These are also for those rogue police officers, those ones that like to brutalize us and harm us and get away with it.
No, we're not doing that anymore.
My man, Eric Garner six years ago.
Another reason why I had this hat made that
says I can't breathe.
Because that's what he said when he was being
choked out by police for selling loose cigarettes.
It's funny. I got the hat made six years after he said
it and six weeks after George Floyd said it.
And there's the whole story about Philando
Castile right there.
The baby was in the back seat. He's told them "I have a concealed weapons permit."
"Show it to me."
He reaches for it and the man kills him.
Kills him.
Where was the NRA then?
Silent.
Didn't say a damn thing.
When you walk around the statue and you see
pictures and birthdays and brief descriptions.
How many more of the signs would you like
to see before it would change your mind that
maybe you're responsible for your own protection?
One of the most frequent things that I've
always heard is that I would be killed by a cop.
They believe that a cops perception of me
being armed is going to be the reason why I get shot.
I can honestly say traffic stops prior to
me being armed are extremely different than when I am armed.
And cops are a lot more friendly and a lot
more open to communication
when the playing fields are the same.
Everybody's out here, peaceful,
you know what I'm saying?
Stop listening to the media, stop listening
to that sh*t.
We're out here singing song's about freedom.
I can't wait 'till we don't live in a police state.
Ain't it great when we win? Ain't it great that we don't live in a police state.
Almost a month ago, if you notice, wasn't
that many of us out there with guns.
Now look at night, big difference right?
Big difference.
We're peaceful, we're always going to be protected.
And that's been my mission.
I believe that I'm channeling my ancestors. I'm channeling activists before.
The police are violent. We will not be silent.
You had in the sixties and before, a situation
where there was little or no help from the
federal government in protecting your civil
rights.
That's not the case today.
There's still the issue of how well are you
protected?
Do you want to totally surrender your ability
to protect yourself to others?
Basic question, is it a good thing to be helpless?
And I say, no.